the economy going down the cheese but
the PM resolute there's light at the end
of the tunnel fantastic making
investment in infrastructure the
foundation of his economic rebuild but
his most pressing puzzle is how to
protect jobs under threat now we've put
120 billion pounds already into
supporting putting our arms round around
workers around businesses supporting
jobs and incomes around the country and
we're going to keep further going until
October and we'll continue to provide
all kinds of support when they get this
country through this crisis in very good
shape the PM says he won't extend the
furlough scheme instead his Chancellor
will look for other ways to protect jobs
a temporary cut to v80 for restaurants
and pubs an obvious place to start but
the Labour leader says when it comes to
furloughed workers in businesses like
this
October's too early to turn off the taps
what we're saying to the government is
don't have a one-size-fits-all leave
support in place for the businesses and
sectors that need it these are good
businesses they're just not able to
operate because of the circumstances
don't let them go bust don't let people
lose their jobs this form the business
secretary says the government was right
to step in but now it's time to step
back it was essential to furlough and
it's really saved our economy from
instant disaster but I also think it's
now essential that we get businesses to
stand on their feet again we've got to
get the economy back up and running
otherwise we inadvertently kill the
economy with kindness you know we do too
much we make businesses too dependent
and then they will fail so you think
business now needs a bit of tough love
from the government yeah I think that's
right I mean there's no doubt that there
are some sectors that need ongoing
support but at the same time it's in
everybody's interest that businesses now
think their way out of this do you think
that the scheme should be extended if
necessary or you think blanket
absolutely no more furlough in past
October I would say it's a very fine
line the trances emergency statement on
Wednesday will focus on jobs and trying
to
get some life into our stalled economy
but no one yet knows how deep the
recession will be or how many jobs will
be lost
it makes the path to recovery very hard
to map mr. Johnson will at least want to
show voters he has a plan
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster